good morning my rural Chum mr. dr.
Robotnik I'm going to give you five
seconds to tell me where it is
wait don't hurt him I loved it I thought
it was great you know I had a little bit
of my concerns my own concerns and you
know people jump right in there and they
will not be ignored
and that's the new world you know and so
I think that was very incredibly helpful
you know I think it was great cuz I had
my own concerns and when they kind of
matched it I went oh good that's great
and you know Jeff Fowler was just you
know johnny-on-the-spot ready to do it
ready to get into it and I think they
did a great job it really did yes
so we're all in this together man I love
this guy this guy looks gorgeous
also his face I had little dots in my
face so all my facial things become his
facial things which is very exciting I
love it yeah yeah I love it yeah I grew
up playing the video game of course I
was 18 or 19 when the game came out so I
didn't really grow up playing it but I
played video games my whole life it was
Atari in television Nintendo Mario
Brothers and then Sonic at the stage and
it was like I didn't play the game that
fast before with a fast character like
that so I was immersed myself in that
and you know obviously he has a specific
look and I I went when all that we were
done filming like I've three months out
when the trailer hit and it was like to
me it put a massive smile on my face
because it reminded me how iconic this
character is and how passionate that fan
base is and so it was like yes these are
people that care that want this to be
right and want to see this movie it was
like fantastic let's uh you know let's
make everybody happy whatever this
creature is I'm going to uncover the
source its power
I love it all I love all the different
colors you know and and something like
this you know I've been doing some
serious stuff and then and then
something like this comes along and it's
just an opportunity presented to me by
the universe you know it's like it's a
gift it's just oh you know somebody left
the corral door open and you know the
Mustang must run you know so it's it's
really kind of fun it was really kind of
great and it's a it's a part of me that
never leaves you know people don't have
to worry that I'm never gonna have that
part of my brain that wants to just have
some silly fun you know
[Music]
honestly I'm so gratified by that kind
of stuff like I have people coming up to
me going i just--literally was the mask
on Halloween or your new filmmakers that
have just broken through that are going
like I started because of Dumb and
Dumber or whatever but like it's a
really fun when you see like a little
kid dressed up as the Grinch or
something like that or they come up to
me in the street and you know their
parents says you know who that is that's
the Grinch and I go I must find a way to
stop Christmas from Gaby you know and
their parents go oh I thought it was
makeup so it's so fun is so it's so
gratifying so you know if if I get lucky
if people like it and their kids like it
then you know I get to see it next
Halloween yeah yeah well he's gonna
evolve you know the plans to evolve him
is really cool
that was an illegal left by the way I
think they are drawn to me you know they
know the projects have always found me
even if I don't know it I'm not aware of
it when it happens
and I'm thinking I'm making a conscious
decision to do something it always turns
out a little while in or a little while
after that I realize my subconscious
mind is is really my agent and my my
maestro and it has its own plan and when
I write something when I sculpt
something when I paint something it's
the same thing it's like I can
consciously decide to do something and
then invariably a year later I I realize
how my subconscious mind was trying to
tell me where I was you know it was
actually trying to tell me where I was
so it's fascinating process to me and in
playing characters is great too because
you know you look at a video game and
there's not much to it you know there's
not much to the development of the
characters and you have to kind of like
really flesh it out and I look at it
like you know character like lightning
starts from the ground up you know and
so all of that madness has to come from
someplace it can't just be madness for
madness sake comes from a feeling in
this character of absolute worthlessness
you know combined with genius you know
so he wants to own the world he wants to
control the exterior and the interior of
every human being he basically is at war
with the world because he was neglected
by it
you know so it's fun to play oh my god
all right what the world's largest
rubber band bulb we got to see it so
within the lines itself we had a great
script we had two incredible writers
write an incredible script which always
starts like that and then Jeff Fowler
the director who I think did it
incredible do you see the movie he did
an incredible job
it's his first big feature film and I
thought he did such a good job when
we're in the booth even beforehand with
a table read if I punches if I pitches I
couldn't say and do whatever I want
because for me it doesn't cost them
extra money we're not rolling cameras
I'm in a booth you know what I mean so
we
do whatever we wanted so and I also just
because I really cared about this movie
I would even say hey if I had an ADR
session can I come in an hour early
watch whatever we done in the past just
in case I can think of any new jokes and
he'd be like of course of great yeah you
want to make it funnier yes so I came in
a couple times saw the movie myself just
so I can keep punching myself up which I
thought was he was he gave us such a
leash to be creative and to be wonderful
I think it really shows in the film yeah
right it was lame game shop was cool
though oh yeah well there's one crazy
thing that I knew wasn't gonna go in but
I don't know if your play the video game
when you when you start a Sega Genesis
or for the skin particular we start of
Genesis if there's a thing that goes
Sega and oh you know what we should
record me doing that so we had me
harmonize with myself in 10 tracks like
we go over say you guys sit and do it
like that
and I was like can we put that the
beginning the movies like let's do it
and so it never got put in the movie but
I have it on my phone it's a very silly
specific that maybe some of your people
that watch this will understand let me
show you how it's done
get out of here yeah time to go I
approached it is first of all I played
the games I realize how fast that he ran
I was like okay I want to find a way to
bring the speed and energy into the
performance and then I read the script
and I was like you know what this is
let's strip away that it's a hedgehog
it's a little boy that is really excited
to do things that has never been allowed
to do things and also now he's allowed
he's allowed to have a friend he's
allowed to do all these things if I
could find a way to bring the energy of
being a little kid and like show him I
know we do this we do this I was like if
I can do that I think then people will
really connect with him a bit more and
almost be like oh it happens to be a kid
that looks like you know what I mean and
then like the the bromance works better
and then the heart works better so that
was the goal I always want to do this
John Ralphie Oh although when sanic gets
hit by anything he loses all of his
coins all of his rings rather all of his
rings so it could be sonic has one hit
and all of his brings argon but Jenna
Ralphie oh just doesn't know what he's
he loses money not even understanding
why or how I think we there's one
callback - Jenna I did a couple of Jim
Carrey impressions in this the there's a
clip where I have a fish on my head and
I go through this thing where it's like
I did this I did this I did this there's
a fish on my head and I tried to do it
like there's a dumb and dumber line this
is very nerdy but where he goes like
that uh
our pets heads are falling off and I
tried to emulate him and there's one
more that I haven't it has the clip
hasn't come by yet sounds like how funny
if I did a little bit of Jim Carrey
impersonation like and just like a
sentence or two throughout the movie so
there's one more that is a total
emulation of him as well but for John
Ralphie I think we did one the worst
I think someone calls me the worst but I
don't sing it alright get in the truck
really I'm gonna help me I guess it is a
little bit my fault that all this is
happening to you yeah I guess like I
guess I've been in a few of them I it
was enchanted that was a little squirrel
like running around next to me and then
hop with Russell Brand doing the voice
of that um it's fun like I have three
kids and sometimes it's nice to do a
great film that like we have this
conversation so many times with I get my
my 18 year old my 14 year old my 7 year
old and sit on the couch and go what
movie can we all watch and it's a tough
one like this there's there's not many
out there but this is the kind of movie
that we can all sit and enjoy because
there's the action and the cute
character a video game character the
kids of love but then this is a humor
that the kids will also get but the
adults it's sharp enough for the adults
they'll love to see Jim Jim Carrey back
in pure form and and and this eye kind
of character that they grow up playing
the video game come to come to life so
yeah it's a it's it was like a no
brainer for me yeah I want to be a part
of that world I thought it sound good no
peeking you bad get rid of it I'm trying
rolled out the window
yeah it's it's really just it takes a
commitment to making it feel as real as
possible right it's like let's not
oversell it that it's you know a cartoon
right like it's let's keep the dialogue
real make it feel like it's two buddies
who were kind of an odd couple at first
and it can feel very natural the banter
and the back and forth can feel and
knowing that Ben's gonna go in and kind
of crush his his voiceover performance
and the trickiest part is like when
you're looking at him like there's
nothing there obviously it's a it's a a
tripod with a piece of green tape or a
blue stuffed animal so you really have
to use your imagination and but really
on the day you could be just looking at
anything it's just imagining what the
scenes about and I would always imagine
just like a little twelve-year-old kid
who's just excited to go to Disneyland
are excited to see the world and like
you have to like keep him calm and that
you know and but you're charmed by him
as well and that was it and she's kind
of roll with that I mean yeah there's
always moments that's that where you're
just like what am i doing for this I do
this for a living people pay me to do
this I'm staring into middle distance
nothing talking to an imaginary friend
and that's my job like what I'm holding
a blue beanbag pretending it's a talking
Hedgehog okay this is really this is why
people in Oklahoma where I grew up said
like are you sure that's a career you
sure you can do that for a living I
don't know but so I've been very lucky
to you know make a career out of it but
it's fun for me it makes me it takes me
back to being a kid we gotta lay low let
me show you how it's done
only that I hope that the show of the
stand comes out before the real stand
happens which is like scary to think
about right now with this crazy
coronavirus thing it's like what Stephen
King anticipated now we're still in the
middle of filming it so it's awesome and
exciting to be a part of something the
Stephen King one of his epic books and
so we want to make those fans happy too
[Music]